according to our source jason is beyond
distraught he still has feelings for
olivia because this is quote a fresh
split that happened in november
where's the director that would mean
they broke up just one month after
olivia began directing harry in their
upcoming thriller
don't worry darling everybody
however another source disputes that
timeline and claims
they have actually been broken up since
early 2020 and quote
the fact that olivia moved on was not a
shock to jason
here's what we do know news of their
split broke november 13th
just one day earlier i spoke with jason
he gave no hint that their nine-year
relationship
was over i haven't seen you trucking
with any trash you know thank you
in work or in personal life because you
did pretty good on that front
at the time production on olivia and
harry's film was shut down due to a
covet 19
outbreak and it sounded like they were
still living together
i know she was really loving directing
this
they're i think a week into their 14 day
hiatus she's editing the stuff they
already shot
they're fun to just you know hear in the
other room
laughing and talking she just works her
butt off
our et source maintains that jason is
quote in
absolute shock but claims harry is not
to blame for their split
nonetheless jason still wants to quote
repair things with olivia
and have his family back together so
here's the interesting thing kev
harry only ended up in the movie that
olivia's directing after she reportedly
fired shia labeouf
and olivia told you she has a no
blank policy yeah she don't like any
mess on herself
for sure well clearly harry worked out
yes